federal investigation into Fox News we
just mentioned is widening a second law
enforcement agency has joined the
Justice Department probe into business
practices at the cable channel the
United States Postal Inspection Service
is now involved its investigators or
financial crimes experts
Jericka Duncan is outside Fox News
headquarters right now in New York
Jericka what's the latest good morning
to you good morning a person familiar
with that investigation confirms to CBS
News that in fact investigators with the
US Postal Inspection Service are
involved in the Justice Department probe
into Fox News now that investigation
reportedly has to do with dealing with
money matters at the network while the
existence of the Justice Department
investigation came to light two months
ago the Postal Inspection services
involvement is new the network in the
meantime has been lashed by a series of
conduct related lawsuits eleven current
and former employees filed a
class-action lawsuit last month claiming
executives Foster to quote culture of
severe racial harassment and ignored
their complaints going back years Fox
News denied those claims promising to
vigorously defend these cases yesterday
one of the network's high-profile
anchors sean hannity tweeted about the
turmoil inside the company referencing a
new york magazine article that said
network executive bill shine was on the
chopping block shine has been named in a
number of lawsuits against the network
hannity wrote about it and said that
shine if he were removed would quote
that to the total end of the FNC as we
know it done and he continued by saying
somebody high up and inside the fnc is
trying to get an innocent person fired
now we reached out to fox news for
comment on the expanding federal
investigation we did not hear back Nora
all right Jericka thank you so much